we're gonna see that we did take it to
the next level by putting cameras there
and then getting a bed together and then
getting the Marquis mash ship sailing
once again the high seas hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to gmod Hormats with the Ebers hi guys
I'm not dead oh come on you could be a
little more enthusiastic hey guys yeah
for some reason people thought one that
you were dead - that I hated you because
we haven't done a video in a while and
like three I got deployed to another
country maybe did you know okay no he
didn't don't spread any rumors but no
it's not because I hate him it's cuz
I've been busy and yamimash has been
busy playing League of Legends
apparently you're only in the top point
oh one percent of the players right yeah
okay but anyway we're playing hell's
island which is the sequel the hell's
prison which is the sequel to Hell's
Resort which was like the first gmod
horror map we ever played together yes
I'm sure you know co-op we played
obviously we literally the biggest like
fanboys of this guy who made these maps
I new core voila
awesome alright would you like to read
the story you are on a fishing trip of
your crew which is just me
yes moniker hmm on our on our marquee
math [ __ ] oh yes the marquee mashup the
captain I hope that's me accidentally
shoots a big hole to the boats engine oh
yeah he does okay this is you then but
luckily he was able to get the boat on
the closest islands huh while the
captain is fixing the engine you must go
to the islands and find some gas oh so
neither of us are the captain we're just
were just crew men but the lackeys I
wanted to be the cat I say that one of
us is the captain okay
yes captain this map is recommended to
be played but Gary's work game mode
otherwise map won't change automatically
you walk too fast and some NPCs don't
work as attended we don't have that but
we're gonna do good anyway right all
right okay anyway sorry sorry captain
play with 2 to 4 friends playing the dog
volume cranked explore everything
raiding notes purely optional served our
purpose just to give us your ok we're
gonna do good all right watch crash oh
we don't have to kill each other yes see
you wait wait you you new how's it get
out of this yeah cuz I know that every
other time we've murdered each other but
in reality we never need to do that Oh
ghost
oh no she's ascending to think I'm
pretty juicy stuck magic where did I
park my ship the worst cap never you
were too drunk you lost your ship
captain I don't have my accent is
wandering all over the place captain
well don't fail the jump cap wait no I
oh my god this is going wonderfully
captain I'm sure dare V crew borough
Duty increasing amount of crime activity
near my favorite close the gas pumps are
no longer active all gas is now stored
inside the warehouse you can pay for the
guys inside the tavern and you'll be
provided with the Irish you know being a
Englishman would ya Reds are you lazy
bum stop dancing and get to work doors
open let me just use my special key rag
okay well this is what I was rude
pirates nor the means here eat the beans
I think if you think real hard about the
letter V I know we gotta my goodness I
wonder for this door oh my god
that took ten seconds oh so dumb okay
you cotton our beautiful there really
look of my new arms that I don't hurt oh
let me go back and get all the skulls
story another day alright you do that
cat mari you take also captain put away
your gun
dear temporary employees mister
phalluses does to call the warehouse key
therefore it has been moved inside a
safe that is located in the darkest
corner who this tavern touching it will
result in permanent loss of a hand hooks
for hands of course cuz our stupidity is
very loud captain well it doesn't really
explain much put our two brains together
I think we can probably saw something I
think it means we should move on to the
next room
I think it means we should go and look
at the stars in the sky oh yes of course
oh look it's two lovers having a moment
ah isn't that kidding
it's a door Oh God Oh baby I got the
baby
it's our British bud baby get in the
room and the stars on the floor rere be
right it needs to play with erections
yeah you might even run again rush oh
god don't talk about baby's blood okay
yeah I think it need to put it right in
one of these protection circles oh I
found a room oh whoa oh I don't wanna
know what's underneath these what's that
sound seems to be coming from behind hey
you stop that now I can't stop playing
with it come hey again it seems to be
bloody footprints in here
you there would be a crowbar what's up
Oh
oh my god it's bit Eliza's we got the
jump scares captain please thank you Oh
[ __ ] things with crowbars playing
horror go God Oh take a bit of a bath
cap your smell all right never mind
anyway no yeah
where was that room at the the wooden
doors oh yeah the one you broke down um
use my superpowers oh oh no this games
getting into it ha ha ha how many crew
boss has a magical power of triggering
every jump-scare apparently how careful
captain it's a bit dangerous over there
oh I feel a dark Bret essence oh this
painting Oh
oh that's a living crap out of me
alrighty then Dark Presence gone away I
meant to give you the gun captain but
when we unlock the shotgun you can have
that one oh here we are cap here sorry
there's a health how body I loved
mmm pip-pip cheerio so we need to oh
yeah you took a good fellow
come back here one would use a via crew
bar to ladies first me meaning don't
have any genitalia
so you're just an sizeable what kind of
M Oh God
note subject number three four seven
we're bringing in subject three four
seven extremely dangerous had it was
causes the subjects is locked by at a
very large metal door in the main
hallway we activated four volt between
just keep the zero steel oh boy oh I'm
gonna touch this thing
hey look I think I see for voltage
switches Oh looks like we need to get
force things to unlock a giant evil
monster hey hey another crowbar I meant
to give it to you you know the next
thing the next thing is yours okay
okay the whole time I'm sorry I hang on
you captain you go ahead through this
excuse me excuse me
okay okay I'm lifting this great you go
through okay
okay go go now behind you okay yeah I'm
coming I'm coming
oh it's closed okay captain best of walk
to you have fun
I got pistol ammo but I didn't get a
pistol I can't join you the door closes
before I can get through I open the door
get back oh come back come back through
the door oh I try I open the door for
you that's that's your fault at this
point I'll take okay I know these new
hands you have they aren't very agile
yet god damnit cotton alright where are
these zombies you're doing just my
admirers they're just docile they're a
little angry there we go
that's a bit of lag coming for all the
way from your country oh my god what
have I done oh hello what are you doing
oh my god what happened sorry
slap me
he pulled the smell thing down so I
couldn't get out and then he got in
front of me and then he talked me into
the fifth I I don't know where you are
I'm back oh oh hey alright wait how do
we get out of here oh here we go okay
yeah I know
oh so with my physics guy Hey look you
could have watched me on the camera oh
yeah
weren't you watching me oh you're not
very photogenic
Wow okay sorry captain I donated my skin
in hands to you and that's how you repay
me
oh no a very generous person you know
that doors open oh whoa oh we go here
I'm gonna find you a weapon I know
there's got to be a weapon here for you
around here really I know there's got to
be another one aha through here okay
it's got to be a weapon for you cops
don't pick anything up I'll try not to
pick anything up how did you pick up I
picked up nothing captain you didn't see
nothing I heard something
hey wonder what the meaning of them ah
well my flashlight just turned off
automatically
Wow watch the gun gun on doesn't bring
captain if this be the fate I deserve
please it ended quickly okay thank you
again there's another good idea any
friend of having this place alright
friends my chef your walk-in the plank
ok yes captain of course ok don't get
hours I know there's guns over there Oh
more guns
Hey ok so this is just a mo ok so we can
go back now
alright this is why not whoa ok captain
this looks bad I mean just close the
door behind us we don't need to get in
captain there's a key wait a second
don't pick it up
I dunno I picked up the key tap magic I
did a bad thing
shoot the star above the boss oh my
goodness
oh damn you're back in here I lost my
gun hi I'm out of ammo I lost my gun
Oh God I use my physics gun to take the
style ah give me the star hey you got
the tire let me beat it with a crowbar
no we did it did you like my song I it
was good song captain it was a very good
train car hello star beating you with my
crowbar oh it's so nice kind log good
good job okay thank you everyone thank
you yes it go on pirates Idol white was
we did it wait huh
well it can it's four or five essences
breakroom bonus la locked No very slowly
very slowly okay we did it it's got a
waterslide
check this wait nope he's another pirate
it's our cotton I think the real captain
the one you were impersonating I'm
actually a spy you figured me out get it
for the Navy and the Marines get it for
nobody
oh no I killed me captain whatever with
ID I was the only one not to wake him up
apparently because I'm stuck in this
room not so good that parolee took 20
minutes longer than it should definitely
I'll cut it down don't worry
but thank you guys so much for watching
and another markiplier and Yami Matt's
gmod horror map but there's more there
is a chapter 2 available right now over
on Yami masters channel so if you want
more of this
check out his channel right there click
on his face click on his beautiful face
I just my teeth too alright thanks again
everybody and as always we will see
that's super effective I bet